hello there reject nation it's bright
and early in the morning and there is a
stranger thing season four teaser
trailer it's called
eleven are you
ready listening that's what it is you're
ready for season 411 because we are
i hope there's some revealing
information in here i hope there's a
release date
john what's the joke you want to make
when you do that
that usually means you got a joke income
and what is it that's the sign that
john's about to say a joke what's the
joke jon
that was that was great i don't have
anything no no come on
what were we gonna say origin come on
wait i'm listening
eleven's listening it's just like
there's two of me i don't know which one
to shoot
[Music]
let's get ready to obsess over every
little detail
[Music]
rainbow room
[Music]
signs pointy yes
seven eleven
[Music]
dr brenner
[Music]
uh-huh i was gonna say i know that
hairdo
[Music]
how are you today i have something very
special
i love it
some strong season one vibes good old uh
eyeball teaser yeah in season two that's
when they
had when she met i was like colleen kkk
yeah yeah favorite spin-off character
they established that there were like
other kids in there and stuff so maybe
it's like going to explore you know that
side of the flashback where you see all
these other kids
and like what's become of that i think
brenner's definitely alive he's gotta be
coming back that's uh that's gonna be my
big victory lap is when he shows back up
and i'm like i
called that yeah even though hopper is
also alive too and they're
making no mystery at all about that i
mean i actually like that this trailer
didn't have anything to do with him the
prospect of getting brenner back i think
is actually kind of fun and exciting and
now i'm just wondering are they gonna
de-age millie bobby brown
if this is a flashback but they had the
control room one yesterday
yeah and they showed some images here
and then if you if you like kind of
match up those little briefs flashes
that you got on the on the monitors they
line up that seem to go with
this scene right here stuff on the
monitor was like disturbing
imagery and they're both like eerie and
uncomfortable there was like blood and
stuff like there's blood on the man the
magic 8 ball is the one that really
stood out the most
the one on the monitor in yesterday's
video had like a lot of blood on the
magic eight ball and there's a really
big close-up on the magic eight ball
that says science point to yes
so you know obviously there's going to
be some type of violent
outbreak i'm assuming it's a flashback
but i'm also going to assume dr brenner
is indeed coming back this season that
tease that we had at the end of season
three where they're like we have an
american here a lot of us are assuming
that's hopper especially because the
first teaser trailer
confirms that offer is back
but i'm under the impression that dr
brenner
is definitely coming back and that's
actually going to be dr brenner in there
instead of hopper oh yeah continuing his
research and helping the russians out
with whatever
upside down experiments into the other
side that they're trying to do
right i can't leave well enough alone i
wonder if they're almost going to do
some kind of like hopping back and forth
in 2011's past this season or something
like that because they've said you know
this one wants to be
scarier than the other seasons
especially like you know
youth mental hospital mkultra
experiments like that's pretty gruesome
and sinister
just in general and then you know and
funny totally funny very funny stuff and
that's what they say is humor
and horror are often based on the same
tension and release so this will also be
the funniest season of stranger things
as well and kids being tortured in a
laboratory experiment always hilarious i
tried not to laugh through this trailer
honestly
i mainly laughed
it seems like it's going back to like
season one vibes though it looks like
we're really gonna see
full-on details of what went on in the
hawkins lab the rainbow room what these
experiments all led to
i have no idea what there is to uncover
when it comes to theorizing with
stranger things i'm a go with the flow
kind of guy
i never really know what it is that
they're going to be uncovering i am
curious though if it's not just
not just a flashback that 11's
experiencing
but if she's doing one of those things
where she's like tapping into someone's
mind it could be kali could be uh we met
her mom right yeah it could be your mom
yeah
or you know whatever the hell is going
on in russia
yeah maybe we're seeing telepathically
into brenner's next batch of victims
through her eyes or something like that
yeah it is like having this flashback
quality
but maybe they could even surprise us
with revealing that oh this isn't in the
past it's actually in the very much
present
the description box just says zero zero
two
slash zero zero four does that mean
we're gonna get like
four teaser trailers i guess that's the
best i
could imagine unless this has something
to do with like zero zero
two of something four season four but
your theory is probably
under one that's probably the better one
okay yeah all right i'm at the first
from russia with love
it's zero zero one at zero zero four
okay so yeah that's gotta be the closed
case closest has got to be they're four
teams coming up right it's
good each one of them will drop at 6 00
a.m several months apart
i'm wondering what it is that they're
teasing with all the kids though i don't
know i got some terrible theories maybe
that's what theories are for maybe
they'll team up with our actual
you know the main casted kids and then
they'll ultimately be able to defeat
the mind flare and put this thing to
rest finally and end the show and stop
the money-making
yeah never mind scratch that theory
all right you know i forgot how much i
love like the cinematography especially
when you're going into this timeline
like this
like dark green tint that they have the
colors are sickly yeah i'm scrolling
through the comments what the hell is
this twerking joke
why is everyone twerking inquisitive
twerking or stranger twerking
i don't understand used twerking
what i don't get this i am confused
twerking please explain
somebody what um you miss out did
somebody twerk in one of the seasons and
we we didn't miss it we didn't catch it
the channel the theorizer he has an
interesting comment
all of those kids transformed into what
we now known as the
as the mind flayer ew so it's just like
a
game where it's just like an amalgam of
different parts and bits and
trying to imagine trying to approximate
some kind of physical form
that's pretty cool that's a cool thing
that would be a
tragic twisted pretty cool thing i mean
it's got 568 up votes
and then does that mean that the
demogorgons are also
the poor souls who were experimented on
but different way
all right guys well stranger things
season four what are your theories leave
them all down below hey why don't you do
yourselves a favor
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button you best believe
we're gonna be covering this show check
out our
stranger things season three reactions
up here on the channel catch you guys
[Music]
soon